on today's show we talked to a young
woman who has concerns about her sexual
values and her friends giving her a hard
time
we talk about how to change your habits
after weight loss
and we talk about how to celebrate the
life of one twin
when the other one passes away stay
tuned
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
so glad you're here there's about 8
million
900 000 billion podcasts you could be
listening to and you chose this when
we're so grateful that you're here
thanks for walking alongside us as we
talk through relationships and mental
health challenges and
schooling stuff and parenting stuff and
marriage to all of it
right if you want to be on the show if
you want to help out a whole bunch of
people who are listening
and you want to get my advice which is
worth about what you're going to pay for
it
and that is not a lot free most of the
time
give us a call at 1-844-693-3200
that's one eight four four six nine
three three two nine one
leave a message and kelly will call you
back or if you wanna use the internet
go to johndeloney.com show fill out the
form and it will go
to kelly all right so we need to have a
family discussion here james kelly zach
you're already smiling listen so i've
been going to counseling lately
and these sessions are getting long and
intense
and not intense as though we're camping
but intense
like whoa and see i just did it right
there
i when i get uncomfortable or i get
stuck or i don't know where to go next
i usually look to the people around me
and i make
jokes at their expense so that i can use
that
joke moment as a springboard into
whatever's coming next
so for instance on this show i'm
terrible at intros
and outros and
so i will look into the booth and see
your two beautiful shining faces i can
see zach out of the corner of my eye
he's usually on check an email or
something so it's all good
i just did it right there god i just did
it
zach you're handsome and lovely and
you're working hard in there on like 80
different screens
and i don't know how to do it and so
listen it's out of insecurity that i
make jokes at y'all's expense
all the time there's jim king walking
through i'm about to make a joke at his
expense and i'm not going to
right i can't help it he's a board
member here at the office
and so i think it's important let
everybody know y'all like my friends
we eat lunch together we hang out
yeah we do we've hung out so i'm sorry
for using y'all as like springboard to
get me from one thing to another
i need to a be okay with transitions and
if i
want to have a better intro maybe i can
practice by myself
like a professional like an adult or i
could just
make our jokes not known to all of
america
like kelly's shirt right now i'm just
excuse me number one we made a joke
about your shirt earlier and i was
calling it back to a private joke that i
made off air
i wasn't trying to just do that then
your shirt is awesome
yeah this is going well but just so you
know
i do the same thing when i don't know
what to say or whatever
if i make a snarky comment so how do we
how do we keep joy in the world but take
out some of the snarks i feel like the
whole world's gone snark man
it's to ask me you and james how we put
more joy in the world seems so
off color i mean it just doesn't seem so
off-brand and i would ask zach but he
just responds to thumbs up and downs
it's fun people like the snark but i
think people should know that we are
friends and that we do actually like
each other
and that the snark is all in jest and
that most of the time it's because we
don't really know what's coming next on
the show and we're just fumbling as we
go
and then i got a thumbs up from zach
just then that's so good
all right james has been to your house i
did
we're not we're not there yet we're
working on it
we're working on it james has said he'd
been to your house and i just got a
little hurt so
well number one he paid number two wow
he didn't
that was a snark see i don't know what
to say there we go all right i'm gonna
go ahead and say we're moving on
first caller here we go that's a little
bit snarky we're moving on let's go to
new york new york and go to kaylee in
new york new york how's it going kaylee
hi john uh so i'm 21 years old
and i've been in a relationship with a
really amazing
guy now for two years um the thing is
ever since i was younger i always had
this moral
that i should not have sex until
marriage
and um i've been getting a lot of
backlash
from basically all my friends and anyone
who finds this out
saying you know no guy would go two
years without sex like this and
it's been really making me question the
situation so much more like
i you know i just all i know is i don't
want to lose him
that's i i'm not really sure what to do
from this point on like i don't know is
it is it fine if it gets to three
four years like how long is really too
long
oh man that's a great question so what
what what put this this
sexual ethic in your head years ago when
you were little
um basically every woman in my family
has done this
and not only just that but uh just sort
of like the reasoning behind
it you know knowing like it you i've
seen my friends also like
really the distractions that can come
from sex and
um like how you can really get to know a
person better without that
okay it can make you blind type thing
and i feel like relationships are so
much more than that
and very cool so my initial
thought is this your body is your body
and your values are your values i don't
care what any of your friends say
your your what you choose to do with you
is your choice
and um if these friends of yours loved
you
and we're in your corner they may give
you grief that's what friends do
right they may laugh and carry on but
they're not
going to demean your values whatever
they happen to be
right they may give you their friend
advice which
for all 21 year olds is about worth what
you pay for right
um so you tell me this guy's amazing and
he's been with you for two years
yeah is he pressuring you too how do
those conversations go
sorry is he what is he pressuring you
too or how are those conversations going
yeah so he actually really doesn't
that's the thing i also feel a bad about
it's
like not even one just the backlash but
two i just feel like
at this point like after two years and
also i've actually known him since grade
six we've been best friends all
throughout high school like i feel like
i know him at this point he's such a
good guy and like
it's also just the fact of oh my god
he's such a good guy he never pressures
me he never
asks for it type thing and it's like so
why
aren't i doing it at this point why
aren't you why are you creating drama
where there doesn't appear to be any
you appear to have some firm values that
you've carried
for as long as you can remember and at
some level are generational or legacy
right they're not the norm and that
doesn't make them weird or wrong
that makes them impressive as far as i'm
concerned um
and then you're with somebody who who
cherishes your values
even when they're hard and so it sounds
like things
could not be drawn up better and
there's some sort of discomfort here
where you are
starting to create fire where there is
none
yeah yeah so are you gonna are you gonna
marry this guy
are y'all having those conversations yet
yeah
like sort of the thing is right now
we're really young and like
first you know he talks about wanting a
solid career like financial independence
and
uh but he does make remarks like oh when
i marry you this or
lifelong goals we talk a lot about but
the thing is i know i'm not going to
marry
him any time soon wait what you've known
him okay you are young
fair you're you're young but you've
known this cat since you were
in sixth grade yeah yeah so at some
point
there's some magic arbitrary number some
age out there right yeah yeah i don't
know
i guess i don't know what what you're
aiming for when it comes to numbers
you're not gonna get to know him any
better are you no i don't think so
you're not gonna have any wild like i
gotta get my club in years out
of my life right this doesn't sound like
you
yeah um financial independence is a myth
right that's not like a thing
like he still lives with his parents
though yeah that's probably not going to
work out
right you probably don't want that
but but all that to say is here's what i
want you to do i want you to
be holy strongly
and firmly committed to whatever your
values are
your body is your body is your body
and your dumb friends in college don't
get a vote
this guy loves you he's known you and
loved you for a long long long long time
and he's all in on your values good for
him
and good for you don't create drama here
where there's none
and man i would really sit down
and think through what spend the rest of
your life with this guy's gonna look
like
i don't know what else you're looking
for or what else you think is gonna come
up in the next one two three five
years that you're just gonna wait for i
don't
i don't know what you're looking for
it's not like you're gonna get to know
him better it's not like you're going to
um have to learn to trust you've known
this guy forever
right now he does have to move out of
his parents house and so
he could do that sooner rather than
later but
in some situations i tell folks man you
should really take some time
really take some time to get to know
somebody before you marry him other
times
man my friend rachel here she got
married super young was it hard of
course it is
i got married relatively young and it
was super hard
and my friends who got married late
super hard it's just gonna be hard
don't get married just so y'all can
sleep together but also don't put it off
just so you can say we put it off just
so we could say we got married when we
weren't so young
at some point that age is relatively
arbitrary especially if you both have
known each other for a long long time
i love your question it's relatively
simple for me
your body is your body what you choose
is what you choose
and um you need to find someone who
honors your values you found that
high five good for you
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud
and it seems that everyone has anxiety
i've been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discussed what anxiety is
what it's not
and how you can get back on the road of
being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining
anxiety today hey what's up we are back
let's go to candace in victoria british
columbia
what's up candace how are you doing
kenneth how are you
good everything going well yes
everything is
fantastic all right so how can i help
what's up so
i am 41 and i've struggled with
my weight all of my life and in surgery
i took the big step to have weight loss
surgery and
um basically i realized like it's a tool
and i still need to do
a lot of work it's not going to fix
everything for me
yes so i want to get to the root of
emotional eating and so that i can have
like success long term for my kids
and my husband and myself oh very cool
thank you so much for
your trust and call here so um to recap
you just had
weight loss surgery how recently did you
have this in january beginning of
january
oh so super recently yeah
okay so um have you seen just the
the the weight loss dive that just falls
off at the very beginning
yes definitely as low 60 comes 60 pounds
congratulations
okay awesome so um
your call is a little bit muffled so
you're asking about um
or you're understanding now hey this
weight's falling off
yet um candace went with candace
before the surgery and after surgery and
you're still the same beautiful woman
looking at yourself in the mirror
and you're recognizing that same
six-year-old girl still looking back at
you
and you want to know how to get to the
root of this thing for the listener
you're 60 pounds down this is confetti
falling from the ceiling everybody's
cheering
yeah what are you still feeling though
um i guess so what it comes down to is
my parents i've watched them feel my
whole life struggle with weight
and i um now you know
like they're in the 60s and their health
is really not good
and part of what helped me have this
push to do this was
i want to be the grandparent that's able
to do stuff with my grandkids and i want
to be active and i just want a healthy
future and so
um i guess just seeing their struggle
and and where they're at has really just
made me go okay i need to do everything
that i can do
and um yeah and i just
i guess i need to find some other sort
of coping mechanisms
yes so what are
is there anything big that you're coping
from or is this just the model you
picked up for everyday life
meaning i would ask what your aces score
is what
your adverse childhood experiences did
you have trauma as a kid did you have
abuse as a kid
or were you all just a family who
loved eating and y'all were just a
larger family
um good question it's um
i guess maybe um kind of both like
um i i have two siblings and they
and my sisters both of them neither of
them struggled with weight
so okay um yeah but it
it comes down to like i think it stems
from
when i hit elementary school age i was
bullied a lot in school it wasn't until
about high school that i actually
enjoyed some of my school years
and so i think that definitely played a
part
um but yeah like no abuse really
just getting middle school can
lodge itself in our souls man and it can
stay there for a long time
so what did those what did those evil
middle school kids what did they pick on
you about
they picked on me about my weight so it
was something i was already
uh sort of feeling insecure about so
like as
early as i can remember it's kind of
been and middle schoolers are ruthless
yeah yeah for sure
um and so are you able to
something has happened now that you've
lost 60 pounds and you've got
so much more to go something has emerged
here
that has made you go oh this is just a
tool not a solution
what's popped up the last few weeks
um well like i said like my
i've watched my dad's health go down no
no not that not that what's what about
you
you are so good at deflecting you're
really good at this
what have you experienced over the last
few weeks
um i will i think it comes down to the
fact that
i've kind of replaced that
behavior like so i haven't been
emotionally eating but i
sort of replaced the behavior with like
just staying busy
and i'm getting to the point where i
realized like
i can't just stay busy and distract
myself all the time because
i'm getting tired yeah okay all right
yeah and so when you get tired and you
plop down just to
watch a show with your husband yeah is
that when the
old food demons come out or just the
default i don't call them demons just
the
the default behaviors um
yeah i would say yeah i mean
my husband's really supportive but he
often will have a snack or whatever when
he watches a show and i
just kind of sit beside him and just try
not to partake in that right
i'm not hungry right hey that is a
losing
uh you're better you're a better woman
than me man
i can't sit there when someone's eating
a snack and just watch it happen right
um so here's the thing in the short term
what you're gonna do the couple a couple
things here
i want and you probably went through
some sort of did you go through some
sort of pre-surgery did they give you
stuff to read or counseling or anything
like that before the surgery
um yeah we i had to meet with a
dietitian for
six months and yeah okay did they walk
you through
there there is it's very common
when somebody loses a lot of weight all
at once
like on the back of a surgery like this
that there ends up being some major
relational challenges
not that it can't be overcome but it
just changes the dynamic
did they talk to you about that no
they did encourage me to to you know
speak like
counseling or psychologist but
unfortunately like my husband is a
pastor so we
don't have it's not something you make a
lot of money at so it wasn't
something we could pay out of pocket for
so gotcha so here's what i want you to
do i want your
husband to go to his church leadership
and i want him to ask them to
pay for you all to go to a few months of
marriage counseling
during this transition time and not that
there's anything wrong
but you are going to need to learn new
tools on how to talk to each other
how to have fun together it's just going
to change the dynamic of your
relationship
and as some of the walls come down
metaphorically and figuratively some of
those middle school voices are going to
come back really loud
okay and they will make their way out in
your relationship in weird ways
it's just some of his basic hey i just
want to sit down on the couch he just
wants to plop down the couch and grab
something to eat
he's going to need to be a part of the
whole family's healing
right and it's easy for that to turn
into
little seeds of resentment or
frustration like oh i just wanna
but right and so what you wanna do is
head that stuff off way
upstream and so i don't know any
group of church leaders who wouldn't
help out their pastor in this way
and it's the right thing for them to do
they can afford it and
they need to make that available to
y'all okay okay
and so if if i'm him i'm having that
conversation at my next elder's meeting
or i'm reaching out to somebody tomorrow
right
um and then the second thing is is i
want you
to maybe for the first time think of
things that you
love that you absolutely
love that you love to do that you've
always wanted to try that you want to be
interested in
you're going to need to learn new things
and this is part of the frustration and
part of the
super excitement here okay
you are entering into a whole new
adventure and it's not just going to be
everything the way it was candace minus
100 pounds or what
what's your final goal do you have a
final goal there yeah
i'd like to reach 160. yeah you want
you want that to be your final weight or
you want to be have lost 160 pounds
oh sorry no so lose 100. okay all right
awesome um so that be your final goal
you know you hear me say this on the
show a lot whatever you end up doing
however wonderful your goals and
adventures are
always remember that wherever
you end up candace goes with you and you
want candace to know some new tools have
some new
skills to have some new things that she
loves so that when you are down a
hundred pounds
you're not just the same those same loud
voices the same
patterns the same repetitive things that
you do the same habits in your life
you want to have a whole new set of
tools to draw from
right so after you get home instead of
sitting down watching the couch we just
go for walks because that's what we do
and we have a joke of the day we tell
our
favorite thing of the day and the
hardest part of the day we go to the gym
together
we're not ever going to a stupid gym i
hate the gym
but we're gonna do some exercises in our
garage together
we're gonna go out with the kids and
kick a soccer ball until i'm so tired i
am laughing so like whatever those
things are
and they're gonna be awkward and wonky
at first
and then you're gonna say after two
months i hate this i don't like whatever
this is
or you're gonna think i never ever ever
dreamed i would love kicking a soccer
ball with my kids but now i love
love it and in fact i love picking up
the soccer ball and drilling one of my
kids with it that's even funny right
whatever those things are
knitting singing songwriting writing a
book
writing a blog whatever those things are
learning algebra for the first time
i don't care what it is but i want you
to spend some time with your husband
dreaming about what life's going to look
like what life can look like
get real clear pictures together and
then just start trying cool stuff
just start learning new habits if you
spend your whole life
trying not to do things that's got a
short-term
life to it okay you are
changing who you were into i'm the kind
of per not the kind of
person i'm not going to lose 100 pounds
i'm the kind of person who plays soccer
with their kids
right i'm the kind of person who always
has a joke ready
i'm the kind of person who will wrestle
with my kids on the floor
i'm the kind of person who will pour ice
down my husband's back while he's
sitting on this recliner or whatever the
things are does that make sense
yeah totally i want you to
order atomic habits by i just lost it
yeah james clear duh um i want you to
order that book atomic habits by james
clear
and i want you to read that book it is
um simple
clear um no pun intended i see what i
did there
and it is a remarkable book on how to
learn to live
with a different path with in a
different way and
i think you will really benefit from
that book i want to tell you
i am so excited that you've decided
you're pl you're reverse engineering a
long beautiful
life which is i want to be 80 rolling
around on the floor with my grandkids
i want to be able to sit on the floor
with them and play legos or blocks or
dolls or dinosaurs or whatever kids do
by by then i don't know you'll be in
some
digital universe of some sort but i want
to be able to play with my kids i want
to be able to take him to the zoo
and laugh i want to be able to fill in
the blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank
and that means i got to start changing
who i am and my health and behaviors and
life now and that's going to alter my
marriage it's going to alter my kids
it's going to alter my faith life it's
going to alter everything
and so i'm going to do the things up
right now they're going to make that
possible
good for you for taking a big scary step
and and having a weight loss surgery
you're down 60 you were more than
halfway to your goal
but now the real work starts which is
changing candace's
picture of herself which is changing
candace's behavior
which is changing candace's and her
husband's marriage
which is changing the household
little step by little step by little
step i'm so proud of you
check out that book make sure your
husband calls um his
his leadership team and they're going to
pay for all to go to counseling for a
few months
they've got to they've got to they've
got to if they don't i've got a
partnership with better help
so go to betterhelp.com and they will
give you some discounted um relationship
counseling
um give them a shout if you can't get to
in-person counseling there
thank you so much for the call candace
we are so excited and proud of you keep
us
abreast on your journey give us a shout
as you make that uh journey
let's take one more call let's go to bob
in phoenix arizona what's up bob how can
i help man
hey i really appreciate the call thanks
for uh taking my call thanks kelly for
getting me on the show i really
appreciate it
really appreciate that uh i
wanted to talk to you today so me and my
wife found out we were pregnant with our
first child
okay would you like to find out
uh november november okay yeah
and then a couple weeks later we found
out that we were supposed to have twins
whoa okay yeah and which i was really
excited for because that's kind of what
i wanted she has twins that run in her
family
okay and then we found out that we lost
one of the twins
oh man i'm so sorry yeah so it's
apparently it's a common thing called a
vanishing twin
um but it sucks because we have
it's our first kid and then we found out
that we're having two and now we're back
to one
yeah which you know the one is super
healthy everything looks great which
we're super
thankful about that but it's how do we
how do we mourn the one but still be
happy about the other
and then how do we make sure it's not
you know living in a shadow
yeah of this you know on
this thing that i could never live up to
yeah man well thank you so much for your
trust on this call dude
um that hurts and
yeah that's hard dude um when when's
your
your baby gonna be born july 25th
or 7th i know i should know that better
hey dude just pick a date
it doesn't matter you're going to be
wrong either way
[Laughter]
um yeah you probably want to when the
your when your kid is actually born
you're going to want to hang on to that
date that's just a good one just to
keep in mind um but right now
everybody's just guessing
so here's
the big picture is this um the grief is
real
and the grief hurts and you're gonna get
all kinds of
the stupidest dumbest advice
and recommendations and all these
idiotic sayings that
people knit into pillows they're going
to be giving them to you
right yeah and do the best you can this
is
this is not going to help a lot
do the best you can to recognize that
people
are doing the best they can with very
limited tools and that people are often
very crude and they can hurt each other
with their grief
their pithy little grief statements
right
and um don't hang on to any of that
nonsense because it's going to weigh you
and your wife down
okay the second thing is is fully
recognize that you and your wife are
going to grieve this thing very very
differently
yeah and that often divides couples up
and it's hard to walk back
once you get divided there and so make
sure you have a
weekly if not um bi-weekly
check-in time hey how are we doing how
are you doing
and give her don't try to solve it don't
try to give her advice don't try
just give space to each other for
grieving this thing differently
okay um i misjudged this horrifically
when we experienced something similar
and um
man i gave a lot of lectures and a lot
of charts and a lot of
spreadsheets and graphs and it was
wholly unhelpful
and in fact it was not only unhelpful i
hurt my wife and
um pretty significantly i i did not
handle this well
and so um give space for each other to
speak so
um i knew this call was coming so i
reached out to a friend of mine
and her job is
having hard conversations with parents
and little kids
and i said hey give me some thoughts on
what are ways you've seen this
this play out and not be successful and
be successful
here's a couple of recommendations that
she made the first thing is
is no full and good it's okay to talk
about
the um the lost twin
with the baby with the young kid it's
okay to have a two or three or four year
old
and to have an extra cupcake at the
table
if you want to remember and honor um
this this lost life in that way
she told me about couples who will write
letters
once a month until the baby's born
after the baby's born for the first year
they'll just write a letter saying hey
we miss you
and here's some things that have
happened in your brother's life or in
your sister's life
and um we miss you and we can't wait to
see you again
and they've she told me about one family
that
wrote letters and they put it inside of
a balloon and they let the balloon
go and they do this on every birthday
the key here is not squashing the grief
and not trying to pretend it didn't
happen and
also not trying to shield everybody
from it making it a normed part of the
experience
and potentially in year three four five
or six or seven or eight or nine
whatever it looks like
um that candle maybe comes or that
cupcake maybe becomes a
quick prayer that cupcake may
turn into a quick statement or that
cupcake may be there forever
right and it's incorporating that into
the fabric and narrative of your family
not acting like it didn't exist
a lot of parents will feel like if i
bring it up it's going to make my
other child the surviving child feel
less than and it won't
it won't if you're overwhelmed with
grief at
first birthday then somebody is going to
hold the kid or grandma's going to play
with it with your kid and then you're
going to just go take a walk around the
block real quick
or your wife's going to step out into
another room and
cry our eyes out for a minute and then
come back into the party grieving is
going to look different for everybody
and make space for it
and also make sure you keep showing up
and keep showing up and keep showing up
because there is something beautiful
about having to be there it gives you a
job it gives you something to do
amidst that grief right um and then find
some people in your life you can talk to
about it
and that aren't going to give you stupid
sayings if you're like me
i found out there was this whole secret
club that i didn't knew existed
of dads who were grieving miscarriages
and they weren't allowed to talk about
it
and it ended up being a weird really
remarkable group
that we all were able to have
conversations and talk about stuff and
then their wives and uh we all talked
and it just became this whole group i
didn't know existed
right people walking around this type of
pain all the time
um so when i say hey write write your
this this young one a letter give him a
name
write him a letter um talk to your wife
about it
how how does that sound does that sound
good does something else
yeah absolutely okay um when
dr jennings told me about the balloon
idea i
really connected with that one i love
the idea of
my one-year-old just getting a crayon
and making their chaotic
serial killer scratch on a piece of
paper
and then me and my wife writing a quick
note just saying hey we miss you
and we we we can't wait to see you again
someday and putting that in a balloon
and letting it just go where it's going
to go
um and floating up in this there's just
something symbolic about that that i
love um
and it feels beautiful but at the end of
the day acknowledge that grief
it's real it is acknowledges others
grief
and then you're gonna love this baby
you're gonna
the thing you're gonna have to worry
about is hugging this baby too much and
that's not even a thing you can do
right yeah
um it will not be weird if when this
baby is born it's the greatest
most extraordinary day and you're kind
of heartbroken at the same time that's
okay
it's okay if you cry so hard you can
you're worried you're gonna drop this
this new kid that's okay too
and it's okay that you are so excited
and you're holding this baby and your
wife's crying
all of that is okay there's not a right
way to do this
there's a couple of wrong ways but
there's not a right way
does that sound good yeah
yeah that'll make sense hey listen bob
it doesn't make any sense not even a
little bit it's a
mess right it's the worst
it's the worst it's the the worst yeah
so why don't y'all do that together
tonight um this is gonna be awkward and
and super intimate and i'm i am
playing with fire here because you have
an eight month pregnant wife right or
seven months pregnant
yeah i want you all to each write this
um
write this baby a letter i want you to
read it to each other and that's going
to give you each at a key
insight into each other's grief right
how each of you are handling this
situation
or feeling this handling is a bad way to
say that how y'all are feeling about
this situation
um read it to each other
and they'll probably be tears there will
be hugs there will be hard conversations
there'll just be silence
all that is good and all that's right
and when this baby's born healthy and
hollering and yelling and your whole
life gets turned upside down i want you
to give me a call back and let me know
how everybody's doing
and we will walk alongside you during
this process and i'm thrilled for you
and thank you so so much for your call
comparing grief is a fool's errand
you feel what you're going to feel and
this is y'all's new adventure man and
this baby's lucky lucky lucky to have
you as his dad bob
all right as we wrap up today's show man
we're going back to the queen
2008
man listen single ladies you got to put
a ring on it
so saith queen beyonce
james and kelly are both dancing right
now zach
both thumbs are up all the single ladies
now put your hands up up in the club we
just
broke up i'm doing my own little thing
and decided to dip
and now you want to trip because another
brother noticed me
i'm up on him he up on me don't pay him
any attention
just cried my tears for three good years
you can't be mad at me
because if you liked it then you should
have put a ring on it
if you liked it then you should have put
a ring on it
don't be mad once you see that he won it
if you liked it
you should have put a ring on it i got
gloss on my lips
a man on my hips got me tighter in my
diron jeans i don't even know what those
are i wear levi's
acting up drinking my cup i can care
less
what you think if you liked it then you
should have put a ring on it
so saith the queen this has been the dr
john dolone show